just going to step away from that story
to bring you more on this developing
story about Dominic Raab there has been
uh complaints made about him there has
been research done into that report into
that we now hear that the Prime Minister
has that report and is now deciding what
to do with it we're hearing lines coming
out of uh Lobby briefing between
journalists and the Prime Minister
spokesman they say that the prime
ministers received the report from Adam
Tolley this morning he's considering
those findings I'm not going to be
commenting further is Dominic Robb still
Deputy Prime Minister yes he is
according to the government's a
spokesperson there let's bring in a
political correspondent Amanda acass
who's sitting next to me Amanda just
remind us a little bit about the
background to this and how quickly we
may get a result well we're told by the
prime minister's spokesperson that Rishi
sunak wants to take the time to go
through this uh carefully consider it
before making his judgment obviously
we'll be hoping to see that report
ourselves as soon as possible when it is
published we're told received it this
morning we don't know exactly what time
so this relates to eight complaints of
bullying former complaints that were
made about Dominic Raab six of them
relating to his time as Secretary of
State for justice previously under Boris
Johnson one when he was foreign
secretary and one uh when he was at the
brexit department they've been
investigated by a senior employment
lawyer called Adam Tolley Casey he was
appointed by Rishi sunak to look into it
to carry out this investigation after
two of those formal complaints were
initially made Mr Rob himself wrote to
Rashid suneck asking for an independent
investigation to be carried out now that
was five months ago this has been taking
a very long time to conclude there are
some reports suggesting as many as 24
even more civil servants are actually
involved in some of these complaints now
we don't know the details of these
allegations which of course Mr Rob
himself has always denied he insists he
always behave professionally at all
times but the former complaints emerged
after a lot of media reporting about
allegations of bullying including claims
civil servants were afraid to go into
his office have been left in tears even
suicidal with their dealings with him
that he created a Culture of Fear with
his incredibly exacting standards even
the notorious report that once he became
so angry at a meeting early threw the
Tomato out of a packed salad at someone
so this is going to be a difficult
decision for the Prime Minister
depending of course what is found in
this report it's ultimately up to him
he's the Arbiter of ministerial
standards and he will decide what to do
but Mr Rob is a close Ally he's Deputy
Prime Minister as well as Justice
secretary he supported him for the
leadership
and it many in the party and indeed in
labor in particular have been calling
him to set down while this investigation
was carried out Mr sunac hasn't done
that some suggestions that he looked
rather weak as a result of that of
course he'll say he needs to wait for
the results of that investigation to
look through it carefully but he's a
prime minister who insisted he was going
to preside over a government of
accountability and transparency
so and professionalism which all of this
is is looking
um certainly rather questionable at the
moment particularly after he's not even
the first cabinet minister who's had a
step down because of bullying
allegations but Gavin Williamson did
um over
um some tweets he sent to a colleague
and the fact he said a civil servant
should jump out the window and slit
their throat so clearly um this this is
in exceedingly damaging situation for
the Prime Minister he's been attempting
a bit of a kind of reset in recent weeks
with his work in Northern Ireland
attempted to Stave off this Rebellion
over the small boats crisis
um but now this he's been waiting for
this to happen it looks like he's now
finally got that report so we wait and
find out how serious it is for Mr Rob
and indeed whether he himself decides he
might have to fall on his sword and step
down he did say if any allegations of
bullying were upheld then he would
resign but it's unclear how clear pick
up that report might actually be and
whether it will end up being a bit more
of a political countless from the prime
minister
Amanda thanks very much for that for now
if you're just joining us here on Sky
News it is just coming up to the top of
the hour uh it is now almost 12 o'clock
we are talking about this breaking news
this lunch time the Prime Minister has
received the report into the allegations
of bullying about his Deputy dominate
Rob where she seen as a spokesperson
said that the Prime Minister has
received the report from Adam Tolley
this morning he is now considering those
findings let's bring in our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates who joins us
now who's just been inside number 10
talking to the prime minister's advisors
Sam many questions for them but they
have confirmed that they now have the
report and to be clear this report sets
out what what the what Adam Tolley has
found but doesn't give a verdict as it
were about Dominic Robb that verdict now
is in the hands of the Prime Minister
and we don't know when he is going to
deliver that
that's right Jane we should see that is
sitting in the building behind me in
Downing Street considering the findings
of Adam Tolley after a five-month
investigation into the Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic raab's Behavior and the
way that he has dealt particularly
predominantly with civil servants who
have worked alongside him as he's been
just as secretary as he was foreign
secretary this means that we could be in
the last few hours of Dominic ribe's
time in government but that's not
certain what is going on right now is
that Rishi sunak has to judge whether
the findings that he is reading about
from Adam Tolley amount to a breach of
the ministerial code and now that's the
kind of document that determines how
ministers should behave and if it is
breached then they can be fired by the
Prime Minister and I have to say Jane if
you look at the ministerial code it's
pretty clear because points 1.1 and 1.2
so the whole ministerial code opens with
a direction that ministers are expected
to maintain High stands of behavior and
to behave in a way that upholds the
highest standards of propriety they
should be professional in all of their
dealings and treat those who they come
into contact with with consideration and
respect working relationships including
with civil servants ministerial and
parliamentary colleagues and
parliamentary staff should be proper and
appropriate
harassing bullying or other
inappropriate or discriminating Behavior
wherever it takes place is not
consistent with the ministerial code and
will not be tolerated that is what the
Prime Minister has to judge whether
Dominic Raab has breached as he Leafs
through the report now we think that the
Prime Minister has had the report for uh
for some hours this morning he returned
obviously from Belfast uh last night
Dominic Robb's diary believed to be
cleared so we could get some kind of
verdict maybe this afternoon but Downing
Street going out of their way not to
confirm any kind of timetable so if you
forgive me Jane I'm gonna stray into the
realm of speculation but hopefully
inform speculation because we have a
point of comparison or two this is the
third time that Rishi sudak has had to
decide whether to dispense with the
services of one of his cabinet ministers
Gavin Williamson you might remember in
November went again over allegations of
Unbecoming conduct text messages to the
Liz truss era Chief wit which were
deemed unacceptable in other accounts of
his behavior when he was uh defense
secretary and education secretary from a
complicated case was the second one that
Richie sunak had to deal with that was
around Nadine zahari the conservative
party chair now in the end at the end of
January Rishi sunata started again to
dispense with the services of Nadim
zahawi but on that occasion he received
the report into his behavior first thing
in the morning it was a Sunday morning
and by a minute to nine we knew that
Nadim zahawi was out the door and would
no longer be party chairman he of course
was replaced by Greg hands who Greystar
screens last Sunday and so in some cases
it seems absolutely possible for Rishi
sunak to make quite a quick decision
about the future of his cabinet
ministers but Dominic Robinson all
together more interesting character more
senior character more problematic
character for Rishi sunak to let go for
all sorts of reasons first of all he is
of course the title implied Deputy Prime
Minister uh he's the second or perhaps
third if you think the Chancellor's the
second most most important uh
conservative figure uh ministerial
figure in this government and when you
consider it he was first Minister over
under Boris Johnson and at that point he
had to step in and run the country when
Boris Johnson had coveted when Boris
Johnson was over in the hospital uh
receiving help with breathing couldn't
function and it was Dominic Raab who was
overseeing the country's emergency
pandemic response so this is a guy who
in all but name has held the highest
offices in the land and has played a
very significant role so to dismiss him
for a series of bullying claims would in
itself be uh extraordinary he is of
course another reason why it's a
difficult decision for Rishi sunak is
that Dominic Robb has been a staunch
Ally for some time although Dominic Raab
had leadership Ambitions back in 2019
when there was the leadership contest to
replace Boris Johnson last summer uh
Dominic Rob didn't run on that occasion
instead just swung behind Rishi sunak
and played a key role sort of going out
to bat for him uh at all those debates
and being a big figure for Rishi sunak
in the media it was Dominic Robb that
was sent to support the Prime Minister
when uh Richardson came to Sky Towers to
Sky uh in Austin in order to do that
head-to-head debate with Liz truss it's
a absolutely pivotal linchpin figure
he's a lot closer to the Prime Minister
I think than many people recognize and
as such I think getting rid of a member
of your own Inner Circle is quite
difficult here's another reason why the
Dominic Robb decision is a difficult one
and that is because
there will be suggestions there are
suggestions that Richie sunac informally
was aware of some kind of problem around
the conduct of uh his uh his Deputy uh
Dominic Robb there have been newspaper
reports over time often uh denied that
there may have been uh problems with the
way that Dominic Robb interacted with
his staff it wasn't until November that
the starting gun was fired on this
particular investigation there were two
complaints that Dominic Raab was made
aware of in early November that prompted
I didn't really think that he had much
joints at this point but that prompted
Dominic Robb to write to the prime
minister to ask for this investigation
uh to take place that is the thing that
is now uh concluding it is the formal
nature of those complaints that
triggered this investigation that take
us to where it feels we're quite likely
to be this afternoon but because there
is suggestions some disputed that there
was some awareness of problems around
Dominic Robbs uh Behavior I think that
there will be uh uh some fear of some
kind of blowback Richardson of course
inheriting uh the crown from Boris
Johnson and Liz trust came in to Downing
Street and stood on those steps behind
me talking uh about the need to restore
Integrity respect and professionalism to
the operation in Downing Street and so
he knows that he's going to be judged
against that when deciding whether or
not uh to keep him but there will also
be a fear perhaps not necessarily at the
top of Downing Street but in some other
parts of the conservative party that it
is um some will feel that it is quite
easy to mount a handful of Complaint to
get a cabinet minister and there will be
allegations there are allegations in
private Sometimes some of this stuff is
politically motivated it's very hard
without seeing uh the reports knowing
the allegations where there's any any
truth in that at all however it is
something that's uh alleged and there is
some parts of the conservative party who
sense a hostility in parts of Whitehall
may be fair in some cases maybe not fair
in others and there'll be a reluctance
amongst some Tory MPS I think to be seen
to give in to pressure from civil
servants some of whom they don't feel
are always on the side of the
conservative party so all around it's
quite a difficult calculation for the
prime minister to me that's why it's
likely to be going on quite a lot longer
than the consideration around the future
of Nadine zahawi when it came to his tax
Affairs around the future of Gavin
Williamson who was the key Ally and
helped him in the leadership contest
ultimately was in the capital office and
relatively Expendable here you have a
guy who's not only Deputy Prime Minister
who stands in for Rishi sunak at Prime
Minister's questions but is also Justice
secretary integral to debate like
whether or not to leave the European
convention on human rights and has been
until recently foreign secretary and of
course
perhaps it was that record as foreign
secretary that maybe gives Rishi sinak
just a little bit more leeway because if
you remember the events of 2021 Jane it
was then that you had the emergency
evacuation from Kabul as part of the
American withdrawal and the West's
withdrawal from Afghanistan and there
are many that saw the event the scramble
to get on the planes that attempt to an
evacuation many people left behind and
criticized not just the American
operation but also the British operation
too and it did turn out that for parts
of that Richard and Dominic Rob because
it took place in August was on holiday
there was an Infamous moment on Sky News
where he denied that he was swimming in
the sea he said uh on the breakfast show
that the sea uh was closed but
ultimately the mishandling of that is
thought to have contributed to the
decision of Boris Johnson uh to strip
Dominic Robb's role uh as foreign
secretary from him and move him to the
justice department but that's when he
gained the title Deputy Prime Minister
all of this I think uh shows that he is
a important figure somebody who from the
is from the right of the party Dominic
Robb becoming a MP for Isha in 2010
um it's sort of back bench campaigners
one of the most successful periods of
his time in politics uh was when he was
campaigning again about uh the potential
for the need to leave the European
conventional human rights will certainly
address how that worked in British law
all the way through his time on the back
benches he joined government and entered
cabinet under under Theresa May now it
was when he was when he worked for
Theresa may he wasn't terribly popular
with Theresa may he made some comments
uh believe from memory about feminism
that she did not like but nevertheless
when there was a crisis for Theresa May
and David Davis resigned as brexit
secretary after the checkers deal it was
Dominic Robb that stood in and had about
five months in the job of breakfast
brexit secretary before himself
resigning and that shows you the kind of
significance that a figure from the
right who played an important role in
the vote leave campaign in 2016 has
assumed in latter days of his career
he's jumped over uh the sort of
middle-ranking ministerial runs above
and ahead many of his colleagues because
he's seen as this figure on the right
who ultimately in 2019 was going to go
for the leadership but all the way
through the years and years that he has
been in the front rank uh of uh of
British politics that have been the odd
question about his behavior there was a
newspaper sting there were questions
about how he ran his private office when
uh there was one individual in that
office who spoke extensively about her
work with him at the stories of how he
had a very regimented regime as a as a
minister every day sending her out to uh
to the coffee shop prep to get the same
kind of sandwich and a same kind of
coachery of snacks uh some suggestions
that he he liked very very precise way
of running his office and when I talked
to Whitehall officials when I talked to
civil servants about including very
senior civil servants about what it's
like to to work in the orbit of uh
Dominic Raab some might say they were
troubled by some Behavior but some uh
don't but that but there is an element
of agreement that he liked doing things
in a very particular way you know
perhaps a more precise way it's perhaps
at points less forgiving than some
ministerial colleagues wanting briefings
in a particular way documents in a
particular way to be addressed and
handled in a particular way and was
communicated his uh that he was unhappy
fairly uh fairly swiftly and fairly
clearly when he didn't feel that civil
servants and those supporting him uh
were upholding the standards that he
believed were necessary now there is a
debate it's a debate that you're seeing
in quite a lot of places frankly a
debate that you're seeing a little bit
with the ex-head of the CBI uh Tony
danker though that is a different case
in a different context but there is a
debate about what different people think
is acceptable conduct in the workplace
and there are differing views and I
think that again is why this issue could
end up being a little bit more
complicated than the stuff around Nadim
Sahar in his tax Affairs a little bit
more complicated about the published
text messages that ultimately uh led to
the defenestration of Gavin Williamson
uh who was the first cabinet minister
under Rishi sudak uh to go
um I think if there is a gray area
around uh Dominic Raab and his behavior
that's exactly the kind of thing where
Rishi sunak where everything that we
know about him has a tendency to want to
personally delve deep uh deeper and try
and get his own handle on the facts and
what's appropriate and what's not
appropriate to then assume that just
because the report has landed that a
decision is automatic or easy if there
is clear evidence that Dominic Robb
bullied well in that case uh Dominic Rob
himself has told Sophie Ridge on her
Sunday show that he would resign so he
has been quite upfront that if he is
Phantom of bullied people then he will
voluntarily reside but it's not clear
just how definitive I think the report
by Adam Tolley will be the language in
the ministerial code is clear but
there'll be a lot of scope within that
report from the way that that eminent QC
has drafted the language you don't know
how long it is by the way uh from the
way that he's drafted his his findings
for there will be findings rather than
specific conclusions uh just how easy it
will be to come down once on one side or
the other of an accusation that Dominic
Raab has breached the ministerial code
so I think that might be the reason for
the delay it's more likely than lot we
get something this afternoon but number
10 being tight-lipped about whether it
will definitely come and certainly say
nothing about web